e noi Appunto siamo due orticoltori ma
anche due musicisti per questo motivo ci
piace definirci ortisti mettendo insieme
i due mondi Ma cosa fa un artista che
appunto mette insieme di un mondo uno
sforzo pazzesco fa sì porta a spasso il
suo piccolo pezzo di terra il suo
appezzamento portatile Preta porté di
terra rossa argillosa che al di sotto
cela la magnificenza delle verdure
bellissime qua vedete ben disposte
verdure strane però vedo qualcosa in
mezzo sono verdure reali verdure reali
Ma che al centro hanno la tecnologia
questa una scheda Arduino il nostro
compito Quello di unire tecnologia e
Natura una scheda Arduino che vedete da
qui si dipartono questi capelli
elettrici colorati dei fili dei cavi che
collegati alle verdure Grazie all'acqua
contenuta nelle verdure quindi alla
conducibilità elettrica riesce a
decodificarne il suono l'energia i
pensieri e le vibrazioni in realtà
questa scheda Arduino è il fratellino di
una scheda Arduino Infatti si chiama 88
che in giapponese vuol dire fratellino
fratellino no Esatto esatto
originariamente era delle nostre parti
perché è stata inventata da ingegneri
dell'oliveto a Ivrea appunto Infatti si
chiama
Arduino
Ma noi usiamo questa ototo quindi vi
abbiamo confuso abbastanza le idee Ma
cosa serve questa scheda serve appunto
per creare come degli degli aprire dei
canali
il ponte aprire
il nostro Ponte interno verso la natura
e riuscire a tirare fuori dalla natura i
racconti della natura delle verdure Ad
esempio in questo caso e quindi la
creatività che la natura ci comunica Ma
andiamo subito a Testare le verdure
vedere se con il tocco riusciamo ad
ascoltare ad esempio il suono dell'acqua
contenuta nelle verdure le gocce d'acqua
vuoi provare con una melanzana qua Prova
Vediamo
senti
riconoscete
io le riconosco sono le gocce d'acqua
che l'ortista ogni mattina mette
nell'orto elettronico
senti l'acqua che Pergola nella falda
freatica di cui ci hanno parlato prima
l'acqua che l'ortista mette nell'orto
alla lunga si accumula
fa un'onda e l'ortista che è anche un
po' musicista In fondo cosa fa Cerca
un'onda sonora per prenderla e farne
delle forme che piacciono a lui ad
esempio a noi piacciono le canzoni
Esatto le canzoni che ci vengono
ispirate direttamente dagli ortaggi le
verdure si rivelano noi si racconta
nella prima a raccontarci la sua storia
è stata un ortaggio triste immaginate la
storia della melanzana
la melanzana la melanzana che si è
rivelata e ci ha raccontato questa
canzone che è un titolo molto originale
si intitola o melanzana
[Musica]
la melanzana
melanzana
quando in frigo da una settimana
non si comporta bene e non sopporta bene
la vicinanza
delle zucchine
[Musica]
si fa marcire dentro perché non regge il
tempo perché la pelle cede diventa molle
e cade diventa aspra e forte e se la
tagli è scura e sotto il sale suda e
piange forte e prega
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la melanzana
non ha la forza
della zucchina
la melanzana nel viola per via di quella
rabbia si sente sole e strana la
melanzana
Guarda la bene ancora le basta una
parola per fare un sugo buono le pasta
il tuo perdono un melanzana Io ti
perdono
la vita in frigo è dura se hai la pelle
scura Lo so lo so lo so
[Musica]
grazie grazie alla melanzana che ci fa
sempre bene al cuore
L'entusiasmo per la melanzana
il piatto di Novara
noi raccontiamo quindi avete capito
attraverso questo esperimento
scientifico tecnologico di una certa
levatura levatura
raccontiamo quello che è il nostro orto
che è un po' un orto Natale se vogliamo
fatto di progetti di idee cose che
vengono che che fruttano ma non certe
volte non vengono neanche però
raccontiamo non solo il nostro ma anche
l'orto degli altri orti di degli altri
perché appunto Si si dice spesso che che
le verdure non escono dal seminato
stanno nel loro orto quindi non
conoscono quello che accade un po' al di
fuori della palizzata tocca noi quindi
Raccontare il mondo al di fuori Gli orti
degli altri appunto il primo orto che
vogliamo raccontare alle verdure Il
primo è l'unico questa sera e l'Orto del
cantante dei Talking Heads io ho letto
ho letto che negli anni 80 Tina
Winehouse
già bassista dei Talking Heads aveva
comprato un pezzo di terra One Street
tribeca New York e ci andava con il
gatto però ci andava a far raspare un
po' la terra così a correre ma si
annoiavano si annoiava il gatto e si
annoiava lei e così l'orto c'è l'orto
questo pezzo di terra passò nelle mani
del marito Chris batterista dei tokinez
batterista
che non sapeva cosa farsene e lo girò a
Jerry Jerry Harrison chitarrista dei
Talking Heads il quale pensò di
allevarci le lumache no disastro e così
questo pezzo di terra da Tina a Chris a
Jerry finì nelle mani di David byrne
Ma cosa verrebbe fatto cosa ci avrebbe
fatto David Birth cantante di Talking
Heads di un pezzo di terra bavoso niente
Ovviamente niente nulla nulla fino a
quando al pomeriggio aveva dato un
appuntamento al brasiliano Tom Zen erano
gli anni novanta come sempre David era
in anticipo trovandosi misteriosamente
le chiavi ancora in tasca pensò di fare
un salto al vecchio recinto stava lì in
piedi dritto a gambe larghe e osservare
un gatto che camminava in equilibrio
Sulla palizzata Quando comparve proprio
Tom il brasiliano Tom che gli disse in
brasiliano
cosa stai facendo David e lui rispose in
inglese essendo americano
guardo i peperoni del futuro
quali questi disse Tom porgendo a David
una bustina trasparente
dentro dentro
c'erano i semi di una razza
straordinaria di Bahia nel 1992 il
recinto di David divenne un orto Urbano
che produsse 30 kg di peperoni rossi e
gialli nel 94 furono introdotti razze
vere radicanti psichedelici Pop
proveniente dal Nepal al Nord Africa da
Cuba tutto un mondo tutto un mondo che
però bisognava proteggere dal gatto ma
era veramente il gatto di Tina lei Negò
sempre
avere quest'oggi non ho voglia di andare
vedi vediamo se riusciamo a farlo no Ok
vedi
i peperoni del futuro
[Musica]
[Risate]
sono buoni
[Musica]
rossi gialli verdi arancioni grossi
gialli verdi arancioni
peperoni
[Musica]
conoscevo un gatto che li studiava
girava per l'orto e li guardava fingeva
indifferenza Ma lì studiava poi Di notte
tu per tu Lui si strusciava si che
bevetepepepepe
[Musica]
[Risate]
poi un giorno il gatto è sparito è
sparito il gatto il gatto è sparito è
sparito il gatto è sparito è sparito il
cazzo Cercalo il piatto è sparito è
sparito il gatto il gatto è sparito è
sparito il gatto
attento è sparito è sparito il gatto il
gatto è sparito è sparito il gatto il
gatto è sparito È sparito la
morsicaturato Forse l'ha preso un matto
oppure un fatto un patto che lui
toccasse non toccasse non toccasse più
niente però
che non toccasse non toccasse non
toccasse più niente però
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Forse l'ha preso un matto oppure ha
fatto un patto che non toccasse non
toccasse non toccare niente però
che non toccasse non toccasse non
toccasse più niente un errore
rosso giallo
verde arancioni
ciali Verdi arancioni
[Musica]
sono buoni
Si è sgonfiato
grazie grazie grazie grazie grazie
grazie grazie
[Applauso]